we're delighted to bring you the seminar
presented by laggards welcome everyone
and thank you for joining us for today's
keynote presentation titled the brain
initiative and its promise for the
treatment of neuro mental and substance
abuse disorders it's my pleasure to
introduce to you dr. Walter Quaritch
it's dr kourosh it serves as the
director for the National Institute of
Neurological Disorders for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the tab at the top of your screen if any
questions should arise during this
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the Q&A box our speaker will
respond back to you via email and as a
reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Koh chefs I
will now turn the presentation over to
him I am I'm the director of the
National Institute of Neurological
Disorders and Stroke here at NIH and
it's a pleasure to talk to you today
about what I think is the most exciting
neuroscience project ever
we call the brain initiative and just to
give you a little bit of background and
what our objectives are the plan today
is to help you to understand how the
brain initiative and the new
technologies that are being developed in
this initiative will enable really
powerful means to monitor modulate and
map brain circuits over the 3ms monitor
modulate and map and the focus is on
brain circuits also because we are the
nationís of Health and the Institute for
neurological disorders we are really
investigated invested in the brain
initiative because we think a great
promise for these new technologies to
more effectively diagnose and treat
neurological mental health and substance
abuse disorders some of these
technologies
[Music]
gonna be powerful in the medical
community but because they involve
monitoring modulate modulating brain
circuits they probably will have
potential to move out of the medical
space and even in the medical space but
more so outside of it there are going to
be some serious ethical questions that
society will have to address John
understand what is the appropriate use
of these new technologies so we're going
to talk about and end up with a talk
about neuroethics just to go back the
National Institutes of Health is the
taxpayers investment in biomedical
research and the NIH as a mission is to
seek fundamental knowledge about the
nature and behavior of living systems
and the application of that knowledge to
enhance health lengthen life and reduce
illness and disability the inds mission
is really a mirror image of this the
focus being to understand how the
nervous system works is to use that
knowledge to decrease the burden of
illness due to neurological disorders
and stroke of note the taxpayer has been
incredibly generous to the biomedical
research infrastructure here at NIH and
the budget which was flat for years
twelve years into until 2016 as seen
increases in the last four years and
another one projected for 2020 and so
the budget of NIH is thirty nine billion
dollars a year and eighty percent of
that money goes to over fifty thousand
competitive grants three hundred
thousand researchers and more than 2,500
institutions and there's a mandate for
about three point five percent three
point six percent of that money to go to
small business grants to develop
products that can improve health based
on the knowledge coming out of NIH
funded research now it's a very futile
system there are 27 different institutes
and I
yes the neurologic Institute is one of
them 24 of these institutes and centers
actually award grants so depending on
what your area science is you may be
more involved with one Institute as
compared to another and many of these
Institute's which will get to fund
neuroscience so actually the
neuroscience budget is about nine point
four seven billion dollars so almost a
quarter a little less than a quarter of
the inds budget goes to neuroscience and
that budget is split among about
thirteen or fourteen different
Institute's
and important to note is that if you
look at all the areas of science
neuroscience is actually the one that
receives the largest amount of funding
more so than cancer moreso than heart
disease now the purpose of the brain
initiative is to revolutionize our
understanding of how the human brain
works and the impetus is to try at the
end of this to make a difference for
brain disorders which are the leading
source of burden of illness in the
United States so if you combine mental
health disorders neuralyzer sores and
substance abuse disorders they are the
leading cause of disability in the
United States and the brain initiative
is trying to figure out how we can
understand how the brain works so that
we can better diagnose and treat those
disorders as its eventual goal so I want
to just simplify the problem for you for
just a moment and ask you to think of in
broad terms about the fundamentals
workings of the nervous system what do
we know and what do we need to know so
I'd argue that very simplistically what
we do know is as Galvani discard
neurons transmit electrical pulses along
their processes and hodgkin-huxley
discovered how these action potentials
are propagated along an axon now the way
the neurons communicate with each other
through neurotransmitters discovered by
cats
we know that signals can be transduced
from the end of the electrical stimulus
at the axon to the postsynaptic neuron
through these chemical neurotransmitters
those are the kind of the fundamental
processes that we understand now kaha
was the first to see how these neural
cells are connected into dense networks
and it's information processing is going
on in these dense networks but that has
been the problem how do you see the
firing patterns of millions of
interconnected neurons and activity and
similar numbers of glial cells that give
rise to a behavior a memory a perception
a thought series of thoughts so the
computer analogy is how does the brain
process information like a computer how
does a computer process information what
are the computations that are being
performed at each of the levels inside
the brain the communication analogy is
if action potentials can be seen as the
letters in the communication strategy
how are these letters form into words
the words into phrases the phrases the
sentences send that the paragraphs
paragraphs that the chapters and these
into the books that represent our mental
life so this knowledge of how the
networks of neurons process information
to allow our mental life is really the
area that has been very hard to crack
and we don't understand the fundamental
principles that underlie information
process
saying in the brain and that's what the
focus is of the brain initiative but to
understand get to this kind of
information we need new tools and we're
taken to a quote from Freeman Dyson who
was a philosopher and mathematician at
Harvard who said that new directions and
science are launched by new tools much
more often than by new concepts the
effect of a concept driven revolution is
to explain old things in new ways the
effect of a tool driven revolution is to
discover new things that have yet to be
explained and for what we talked about
in the last slide what we need is a tool
driven revolution to discover how
network activity in the brain leads to
our mental life or many behaviors
thoughts language and so forth now
technology has had a tremendous effect
on understanding the nervous system
particularly if you think about in my
career coming out of medical school in
the mid 70s when there was the first CT
scan we were quite excited to see a
living brain in a person using x-ray
tomography but look at that picture from
1974 one really only gets the resolution
to be able to see the size of the fluid
filled ventricles those black areas in
the middle very little about the
structure of the brain but over the next
decades MRI came on the scene and the
type of resolution that you can get with
an MRI scan is almost at the level of
what you would see if you cut a brain
and stained it seen here on the right
panel
and in fact MRI has completely
revolutionized the practice of neurology
neurosurgery where there are structural
lesions that one is interested in and
following and detecting and yet it's had
very little impact in areas such as
higher tree substance abuse disorders
where the struck there are not major
structural changes but the circuit
function is can sometimes be extremely
disordered and yet oblivious to our
ability to see now can one think about
trying to see that type of information
in the brain and that's what the brain
initiative is about and the areas that I
want to point out are the complexity of
the problem but also the imagination of
scientists to allow us to kind of crack
into this code of information processing
so the video that's going to show next
it's just an example of the complexity
of the interconnections between neuron
areas in a mouse brain a slice of mouse
brain and the technology the really
earth-shattering technology is a
technology called clarity in which
scientists called deser are f ed Boyden
develop a technology to take the lipid
out of the brain without affecting the
structure and that makes the drink the
brain transparent translucent so that if
you have a fluorescent marker for any
molecule you want now you can see that
how that molecule is arranged and here
you'll see a molecule that stains on
neurons and their processes so please
play the video
the video that you just saw has
complexity in it at one scale but as
well show later the problem with
understanding circuits of the brain is
the immense the immense difference in
spatial and temporal scales that have to
be that have to be understood and we'll
get to that in a second but again to
emphasize the brain initiative is trying
to get to see circuits in action to
understand how the brain controls how we
move plan execute actions and remember
how to monitor and manipulate circuits
for improved neurological or mental
health function and how disordered brain
circuits cause these neural mental or
substance abuse disorders and as Freeman
Dyson wrote to try and get at this
problem we need new tools we need new
technologies and so the brain initiative
has a focus on technology development
and actually the N in brain stands for
neuro technology so brain initiative is
brain research through advancing
innovative neurotechnologies and the
first five years of the brain initiative
which we were just now ending had a
tremendous emphasis on technology
development led to abilities that no one
really imagined we'd be able to get to
in five years the second five years of
the brain initiative which we are now
embarking on is has a focus heavy focus
on using those technologies to do
discovery driven science and increase
our fund of knowledge about how the
brain works but the second five years
will continue to have a similar focus on
neuro technology development and
dissemination as well the brain
initiative has really eight pillars and
I'm going to go through these so you can
see what it looks like in totality and
then we'll be giving you certain
examples but very small number of
examples in each of these areas the
first pillar is understanding
understanding diversity of cell types in
the brain so the human brain has by
guests best estimates eighty five
billion neurons symbol a number of glial
cells and so the diversity of the brain
cell types is tremendous and we don't
have at this point a very good
understanding of that diversity so the
first pillar of the brain initiative is
to try and understand all the different
cell types in the brain now as we talked
about before as kaha indicated for the
first time these cells are not sitting
isolated dish but they're interconnected
and they're heavily interconnected and
so what we'd like to do is to understand
those connections and the second pillar
is then to map the circuits of the brain
but at the multiple scales that are
important and these this there is the
problem because information processing
is occurring at the molecular level say
at the synapse level or at the ion
channel level so nanometers scales to
information processing across synaptic
junctions to a cell with multiple
dendrites multiple axons and then these
cells are interconnected into a nucleus
the nuclei are interconnected across the
brain and so the the spatial scales
which information processing is
occurring is really quite daunting so
the maps are occurring at different
scales the ultimate however is to see
circuit activity in action and as the
brain is driving behaviors or processing
information that requires the ability to
see brain activity either the fire
of neurons the calcium changes that
occur when neurons firing or
neurotransmitters crossing and
activating postsynaptic cells if one
could see all the brain cells and their
activity with regard to a behavior then
one could develop potential models that
correlate neural activity to a behavior
but those would be correlations to try
to get from correlation to causality
when what needs to do is to build the
model and then change the activity of
the neurons and see if the model then
predicts the change in the behavior and
that requires modulating the neural
activity and so technologies that would
allow one to do that to understand
causality in terms of how neural network
activity leads to a behavior that would
be a tremendous goal to attain now when
we first show the slide with what we
know on one side we don't know on the
other side we talked on the side we know
about really fundamental principles how
the cells are connected how information
is processed from one neuron to another
but on the in the area of understanding
information processing we have no
understanding of the fundamental
principles or the the processes that are
the computational processes that go on
to lead to a behavior so understanding
these fundamental principles what I call
the language of the brain the words the
phrases the sentences these are the type
of computational side of the brain
initiative that's going to be very
important and as one might imagine many
of the work that we talk about is best
done in animal research but we really
would like to understand how that
research and animals translates
understanding of the human brain and
then to go
understanding these pieces the maps the
brain in action the causality to give a
more holistic view of brain function so
that's the seventh pillar from brain
initiative to the brain brought out in
the last Advisory Council the director
on the brain initiative was a second was
a font another pillow called the
organization of science so neuroscience
has been predominantly done in single
laboratory single PI's communicating
collaborating on particular projects but
to understand how the brain works and to
really try to understand how all this
information is processed across
tremendous temporal and spacial scales
we require a real team effort and so in
the brain initiative there is an
emphasis on building teams to solve big
problems that are really hard to get at
particularly in terms of scaling up or
knowledge on how into how the brain
works now we're very fortunate that the
brain initiative is funded by Congress
to the level now that was in the
professional judgement of the advisors
that put together the first Brain 2025
report that was kind of a roadmap for
how the brain initiative should go ahead
they recommended that a budget somewhere
around five hundred million dollars a
year would be what would be needed and
that's exactly where we are now so we're
really grateful to the Congress for
understanding the importance of the
brain initiative and supporting it the
brain initiative in this first five
years has led to a tremendous number of
new technologies and new knowledge about
how the nervous system works have been
over nine hundred publications on say
understanding how to image thousands of
neurons in the wake behaving animal or
developing a super resolution imaging of
molecules using particular
signaling molecules that will blink and
the the the characteristics of the
molecule is being stained can be encoded
in the actual blinking kinetics of of
the of the imaging marker or ways of
doing stimulation using light of neurons
so that one can actually stimulate
multiple neurons at the same time using
optogenetic techniques
that will cause our neurons to fire in a
pattern that's up to the investigator to
set and this has led certainly to some
of the ethical issues as well that we'll
talk about in future next couple of
minutes and the brain initiative to say
simply put is actually also funding our
research and their ethics related to the
brain initiative so if we think about it
out is understanding how the breakage
into understanding the human brain and
treat disorders of the nervous system
they recall that the first pillar of the
brain initiative was understanding cell
diversity 85 billion neurons in the
human brain eight point five billion in
the mouse and this has actually been the
signature project of the brain
initiative so far and that's because
high throughput methods became available
to do single-cell analysis of brain
tissue and this has allowed scientists
to identify a transcriptomic signature
for different cell types but instead of
doing it at a hundred or 200 cells at a
time it can now be done at up to a
million cells at a time and this has
launched a team of scientists to do the
brain cell type atlas of the mouse and
this is well on its way the mouse is
eight point five billion nerve
runs and the transcriptomic analysis
will give us a scaffold that identifies
different cell types based on their
transcriptome but of course there are
other characteristics of the cell the
lineage that cannot connectivity the
firing characteristics the morphology
that all needs to be filled then as well
and added to the transcriptomic cell
characterization but those latter areas
are much lower throughput and the
ability to really get at the entire
mouse brain really rests now with the
high throughput abilities but to do
single-cell transcriptomic analysis I
should say that incredibly powerful
consequence of the cell census project
is the development of tools that give
you genomic access to particular cell
types in a very precise manner and
that's because the transcriptomic
analysis is giving folks the ability to
identify cell type-specific enhancers or
transcription factors to which genes can
be hooked up and these genes say a gene
that leads to the expression of a
channelrhodopsin allows you then with
say light to turn on or turn off a
particular cell type and so with the
transcriptomic knowledge we're now able
to have a cell type specific genomic key
into these different cells this is
actually a very big brain team project
brain initiative team project and much
of this is being led by the Allen
Institute which is an institute that's
dedicated to understanding brain circuit
activity and so this was incredibly
fortunate to have this group assembled
and ready to take on this tremendous
project the next video I'm going to show
you is an example of some of the
technologies that have been developed
should be actually see with like
microscopy across large brain regions
very quickly and the purpose of this is
not only to be able to see structure but
also to be able to see and I'll show you
in a bit the activity which is captured
in optical signals as brain cells fire
so this is from the Hillman lab of
Columbia a very very high speed
volumetric microscopy please show the
video
you
now I want to tell a little story which
is really again a fascinating one
something that one would not have
predicted but has indeed had significant
impact so when we are trying to look at
brain circuit function across the brain
the scales range from you know
nanometers to you know multiple
centimeters and if one wants to get
really intricate detail one would have
to do electron microscopy throughout the
whole brain and certainly people were
doing this and we'll show you some of
that but that is incredibly labor
intensive time intensive and expensive
and not very translatable to multiple
different laboratories I did talk to you
previously about the technique called
clarity which allows you to take the
lipid out of the brain make it
transparent so that you can label with
an antibody or an antibody for a
molecule of your interest and and you
can then see that how that molecule is
distributed in the brain very powerful
technique but it's at the light level
how would one say get to the resolution
where you could see connected to a
molecule on the other side of the
synapse right now you would need
electron microscopy interestingly ed
Boyden at MIT develop a technology to
get you there with light microscopy what
he did was to use the type of clarity
method to make the brain translucent and
then he embedded the brain in a polymer
and then added water and the brain
expanded but the structure was not
distorted and with this expansion
technology and then you
a highly-developed light sheet
microscopy is able to see and scan
across an entire brain but can actually
see molecules such as the pre and
postsynaptic molecules because now with
the separation that occurs with the
expansion technique those molecules are
separated from another each other enough
to be seen with light microscopy so I'm
going to now show the video
this video was an entire Drosophila
brain and they have been able to do this
within about three days of work of
scanning an entire Mouse cortex also at
the same amount of time and of course at
with electron microscopy that would take
many months maybe even a year so
interesting technologies that one would
not have predicted but have shown to be
really incredibly important now the next
video which I'm going to show is from
Jeff Lichtman slab Bobby Kasturi and
it's a very tiny tiny piece millimeter
piece of cortex but what it does show is
the complexity at the very fine temporal
scale so we've seen you know in the
first video I showed the the mezzo scale
and this is the real micro scale please
show the video
you
so this video demonstrates the
complexity of the the connections
between not only the neurons but between
the glare and the neurons and and to get
a complete knowledge of how brain
circuits are functioning we really have
to understand you know from this level
all the way up to across the brain level
now the next pillar
besides maps is how do you monitor brain
activity for years scientists would
stick an electrode in a neuron in the
behaving animal recorded electrical
activity as the animal sees particular
stimulus or makes a certain movement and
try to develop a model for how that
activity led to the be always involved
in the behavior but I'd argue that
similar trying to understand Gone with
the Wind and you can see the movie over
and over again but each time you can
always see one pixel on the screen
Knology to what we past have been able
to do with the single electrode
recordings optical techniques where you
can develop a transgenic Mouse or into
an area brain that will cause expression
of a molecule lights up when calcium
flows into the cell which will occur
with action potentials allows you to see
as you can see here the activity of
neuron firing in here hundreds of runs
at a time and the technology now such
that over long periods of time when you
substitute the OPEX go with say a
plastic translucent skull so now
scientists have the ability at least at
the surface level to be
to see a large number of neurons firing
in a particular behavior and the trick
then becomes and how do you analyze this
type of activity understand the actual
properties of the activity of the
network that leads to a behavior
there are also means that have been into
neurons that will give an optical signal
when a neurotransmitter this one
dopamine binds to its receptor so these
have sometimes been called sniffers and
they have optical signals that you dizzy
lease in real time of neurotransmitters
and this I this technology is just
beginning
but many chemical are essentially be
labeled and so one would have the
ability to see a chemical release all
over the nervous system in a very
specific manner another technology to
monitor brain activity
now modulating brain activity and
turning on or turning off neurons isn't
also an incredibly powerful technology
that's been developed and utilized in
the brain initiative the earliest
technologies were with opto genetics
where a gene is inserted and with light
that gene will turn on a channel that
will either turn on the cell or turn off
the cell from firing and you can do this
in a very cell specific manner and only
turn on or turn off this nucleus of
cells that you're most interested in
there are also people working on ways in
which once that artificial gene is
expressed in a neuron that it can be
activated by say the nerve chemical that
the animal eats so called chemo genetics
or by an ultrasound pulse from outside
the head so called sono genetics or
electromagnetic radiation from outside
the head called magneto
genetics and each of these are working
to some there are some different degrees
in animal experimentation at this time
so just to summarize this allows one to
have really precise ability to
manipulate and modulae neural activity
in a very precise manner using these new
tools this is a complicated slide I will
go through all of it but it's just a
very interesting example from a Greg
Shearer and mark Spitz's lab at Stanford
and so they're interested in pain and so
I take you to look at the bottom tracing
where you can see these kind of blue
patches the F and on the left side you
see the experiment performed in a normal
animal and one side called the test
plate is cold and the other side which
is very dark blue is a control
temperature that the animal is perfectly
comfortable with and what you see is the
animal spends all its time in the on the
plate that it's at the temperature that
they're very comfortable at and then
they show something very similar in an
animal that's developed a neuropathic
pain syndrome by a compression lesion to
the sciatic nerve here again you see the
same behavior if anything the animal
spends less time on the cold plate and
what they were able to do is to find
cells neurons in the basal amygdala that
are responsive to pain but the
remarkable thing about these neurons is
they use a technology at chemo genetic
technology to turn off the cells and
when the cells are turned off just these
cells in the basal lateral amygdala the
animals have normal ability to detect
painful stimulus but they lose all the
negative emotion that goes along with a
painful stimulus
if you go back to F again and you see in
the neuro path on the right side the
neuropathic plus saline so this is the
neuropathic animal and they give the
animal saline and again you see it
doesn't spend any time on the cold plate
all on the comfortable temperature plate
but if you give a chemical called CNO of
clozapine it will activate an artificial
receptor in the basal amygdala to turn
off these cells and then although the
animal can detect a painful stimulus it
doesn't really care it'll spend as much
time on the cold plate as on the
comfortable temperature plate so it's
just an amazing discovery if one was
looking for a mechanism to treat chronic
pain this would be perfect you don't
want to take away someone's ability to
detect pain oh they'll hurt themselves
but you would like them not to have that
kind of negative emotional painful
perception which is what causes their
suffering so an example of finding cells
turning them off for a really tremendous
impact now to get to where we want to go
we want to understand what are the
grammatical rules for information
processing in the brain and this is
going to take a tremendous push to bring
people who are well schooled in theory
modeling mathematics computational
biology to be able to see the data that
the investigators are collecting the
network activity data correlated with
very precise deficient definitions of
behavior and trying to understand what
those correlations are develop the
models now with the ability to
manipulate those networks we can
actually test the models because if we
have the right model we make a
perturbation
in the firing pattern we should be able
to predict what the change in behavior
is so there is a tremendous amount and
growing amount of research in this space
in the brain initiative now I'm going to
pivot a little bit to the potential and
actual benefits to patients so the brain
initiative has neuroscientist Sandra
nears clinicians and ethicists involved
in understanding how the brain works but
there's also a group that is trying to
jump the gun to bring this technologies
to people to improve their burden of
illness and this is going on in research
that is trying to manipulate circuits
for health benefit and people with
obsessive-compulsive disorder
stroke Parkinson's epilepsy chronic pain
depression and even blindness and we'll
show some of those examples now the
first one I want to talk to you about is
a closed loop deep brain stimulator
that's been developed for patients with
parkinson's disease now you may know
that deep brain stimulation and say the
subthalamic nucleus is a very effective
therapy for the motor symptoms of
Parkinson's at least at the early and
mid stages of the disease there is
however a potential side effect of the
stimulation and that is called hyper
Keynesians where in Parkinson's what is
usually very great a kinetic with slow
sometimes absent movements but with over
stimulation one develops Corea kmen
--tz-- which are also annoying to the
patient and to others so how would one
basically tune a stimulator to avoid the
hyper Keynesians and that's what was
done in this experiment what they find
is that there's a if they measure
electrical activity over the service
the brain with a recording strip that
there's a gamma oscillation that occurs
in concert with the hyperkinesis and so
what they have done is connected the
recording strip to the stimulator and
when there's a sign of this gamma peak
in the electrical activity of the
quartet turn down the stimulation to the
deep brain these is from occurring but
continues but the patient continues to
have control of their brady kinesia so
for example or a early example of a
closed loop stimulated where the
stimulation that's occurring in the
brain is driven by activity that's
measured in another part of the brain so
this is really a concept that over time
one can see how this could be used in
multiple different venues this our
example I'm gonna show a video in a
scope though the video is actually
showing you okay great so this is a
video showing a very similar idea and
someone with essential tremor whether
there's a deep brain stimulator in the
thalamus now essential tremor only
occurs when the person begins to move so
what they've done here is they have a
second recording electrode over the
surface of the brain that detects the
signal that occurs before someone
actually moves and they use the
connection to stimulate the deep brain
when they pick up that activity so the
stimulator only stimulates when it's
needed when the person is about to move
now this has less in the way of
preventing side-effects but one big
advance the emulator is not going all
the time and it led to
tremendous increase in time before
battery changes are necessary which is
important because battery changes here
require neurosurgery so another example
of a closed loop stimulation we also
have stimulation experiments going on
and people who suffered stroke with the
idea that stimulating certain circuits
particularly in the cerebellum may
enhance their recovery after brain
injury there are also experiments going
on in people that allow you to collect
and monitor brain activity to try to
correlate it with a particular behavior
and the video I'm going to show you now
is from dr. edward chang who was an
epilepsy surgeon and has patients who
come into the hospital to try to find
out where their seizures are coming from
where then neurosurgery can remove the
locus of the seizures but to do so these
patients need to have a grid of
electrodes placed over the surface of
the brain and record electrical activity
for days to really hone in on where the
seizure is coming from lucky and
fortunate for the brain initiative many
of these patients volunteer to have
studies done where their electrical
activity is actually correlated with
other behaviors besides seizures and
here are dr. Chang his most interested
in the ability to speak so the he will
be collecting data over the surface of
the brain that is responsible for the
movements of the pharynx and larynx that
give rise to speech and has been able to
actually decode this electrical activity
to predict what the person is actually
thinking about saying and one could
imagine for someone with a Mitrovica
lateral sclerosis ALS or a severe brain
stem stroke where they can't talk but
can they can still activate their motor
cortex for speech that this can be
hooked up to a computer and they
actually be allowed to speak again so
please show the
you
the premature seeking is sign the
livonian wills
the proof that you are seeking is not
available in books
the provincial were seeking is sign the
livonian moves
she feel leave in must massing across
sites
shipbuilding is a most fascinating
process
she feel leave in must masse me process
the next slide shows another example
where instead of using electrical
activity that's captured from underneath
the skull at the time of epilepsy
Monitoring a similar idea is using EEG
activity that's captured over the
outside of the skull by electrodes to
actually help someone move a prosthetic
device so it may be that the information
from inside can give us precision
control over say language production but
we may be able to get from the more
gross EEG signal the ability to enhance
the control of say a prosthetic device
so this is done by dr. ben hay when he
was at and soda the next video that i'll
show you is an example of trying to
bypass the anterior visual system and
someone who's blind because they can't
their eyes are no longer functioning but
but we can capture video information
through say a video camera and then try
to transmit that information right to
the back of the brain which is the
computational area for visual processing
after losing his sight in a car accident
Jason Esther Hazen never dreamed he'd
see light or movement again but with the
flick of a switch
well his world suddenly grew brighter I
still can't put it into words I mean
from going from being able to see
absolutely nothing it's pitch black
- all of a sudden seeing little flickers
of light move around while it's not
normal sight a groundbreaking device
implanted and Jason's brain at UCLA
health allows him to navigate the world
around him being able to tell where a
doorway is being able to tell where the
sidewalk begins or ends or where the
crosswalk is are all extremely
meaningful events that can help these
people regain some form of Independence
dr.nader Perotti and implanted the
device made by second sight over the
visual cortex in Jason's brain the Orion
device converts images from a tiny video
camera on a pair of sunglasses into a
series of electrical pulses those pulses
stimulate electrodes and Jason's brain
that let him see patterns of light that
act as visual cues we basically have the
video camera in the video processing
unit functioning or performing the
functions of what the eye does and we go
directly back to the brain by moving his
head Jason can distinguish light areas
and objects from dark little white dots
on a black background
it's like looking up at the stars at
night only the world's second person to
receive the device Jason is helping the
technology to grow more useful as he
learns what each flicker of light
represents someone moving across the
room walking past me or walking away
from me or it's a light against the wall
it was just amazing to have some form of
functional vision again now he can
perform everyday tasks he couldn't
before like sort laundry and safely
crossed the street and with a little
practice days in the camera they say
that I'm not cheating Jason continues to
expand what he can do at UCLA health
this is barb consiglio reporting
please show the video
so as you can see there are many
experiments going on now that could lead
to short-term health benefits for
patients with neurological mental health
and substance abuse disorders and these
all involve manipulating circuits that
are involved in those disorders the
other area where I think there's going
to be a tremendous advance is in
understanding the neural pathology that
underlies different disorders so
currently neuropathology is done under
the microscope identifying whether
there's a loss of neurons an increase in
glia region of brain that looks damage
where the wires and connections between
the brain areas are missing but it's
really quite gross and it's not
quantitative very much
the single-cell transcriptomic analysis
I talked to you earlier about which is
leading to the cell census project
didn't say the mouse brain and soon to
be the human brain those technologies
are already being applied to the
analysis of diseased human brain say
here an example we you we saw looking at
single-cell transcriptomic analysis and
they small region of brain and people
with Alzheimer's disease that can
actually see differences along the
pathway of health disease and
Alzheimer's and actually found really
write quite remarkable gender
differences in in the effects of
Alzheimer's on the single-cell
transcriptomics the other example from
dr. Cheung have at MIT using the clarity
technique enhanced to be able to see of
course large regions of brain the brain
cells and their connections and this
also can be done in postmortem
human tissue I should mention that the
transcriptomic analysis that is right
now we're evolution izing neuropathology
comes because
it turns out that the RNA that's present
in the nucleus of cells is almost as
good at cell typing as the RNA that's in
the cytoplasm and associated cells and
the importance there is that in autopsy
brain one cannot get the RNA from the
cytoplasm from the associated cells but
one can get the nuclei and so these
transcriptomic analyses in disease or
topsy brain is occurring in the analysis
of either RNA or chromatin structures in
nuclei and and that that was again
something not really quite expected when
we started but has really transformed
our ability to understand neuropathology
i'm going to pivot now to the discussion
of neuro ethics and right from the
beginning and the brain initiative
president obama he asked his bioethics
Commission to consider the ethical areas
that are going to be challenges for the
brain initiative and they published two
volumes grey matter one grey matter -
and then at NIH we started a neuroethics
working group that would help integrate
neuroethics
into the brain initiative at NIH and
this has been incredibly helpful over
the over the time of the brain
initiative now what's the special what's
special about the brain initiative in
terms of their ethics well we talked
about the three M's which are the core
principles in the brain initiative to be
able to monitor map and modulate brain
activity and brain circuits so
monitoring brain activity in a human
brings up some really tough issues
questions and particularly around
privacy particularly around what areas
of thought one would capture activity
for
we talked about activity that gives rise
to speech but could we think about
activity that gives rise to your
thoughts your inclinations your
preferences we talked about modulating
brain activity in patients with
Parkinsons ease or obsessive compulsive
disorder post stroke what about
manipulating modulating brain activity
to win a prize or learn math faster or
do better on computer games these are
also issues that these technologies will
will actually challenge society to come
to grips with the neuroethics
group at NIH has put together a simple
guiding principles for the brain
initiative many of these are very
intuitive but but really important in
terms of helping the scientists the
human studies are bees to try and think
through are the consequences of some of
this work so safety being paramount
[Music]
discussing with patients how the
research will affect their capacity to
take responsibility for their actions
autonomy agency privacy for instance
predicting and planning for the malign
use of these tools and technologies
which I hinted at a second ago and
advising caution and moving neuroscience
tools and technologies into the medical
and particularly the non-medical uses to
identify and address specific concerns
of the public about brain and how it
works the brain is really who we are so
it's really quite personal and we have
to be cognizant of how the public sees
this work understands it so encouraged
education and dialogue with the public
and then to behave justly and to make
sure that the benefits of this research
is accessible to the people who really
need it so those
the kind of the guiding principles that
the group put forward an example of
something that one should think about
neural link is a company Elon Musk has
had many successes in his career moving
science into the commercial space and he
and his company called neuro link has
developed breakthrough technology to
record the electrical activities of
electrical activity using a set of
really fine but precise electrodes this
has been something that the braininess
have been working on and they have they
have really exceeded all expectations
and this is gonna be incredibly
important and say folks who have
paralysis and helping them to control a
brain computer in the first to move an
arm or maybe walk again but whether or
not we want to use this technology to
drive a car is something that we need
Society will need to think about over
time we are actually also funding
research in their ethics in areas around
the brain initiative so actual research
in this space is ongoing and and some
interesting papers have already come out
is particularly with regard to the
ethical issues around implanting
patients with stimulators for research
what happens what do we do how do we
take care of that once once the research
is over with for instance they are the
brain initiative has been able eaded by
two major reports the first I mentioned
called brain 2025 was the initial report
that went to dr. Collins seen here in
the middle and it is kind of a Bible for
the launch of the brain initiative and
many of the principles I talked about
are outlined I would encourage you to
read that it's available on the web
brain 2025
there was a halfway point report as well
which was just delivered a couple of
months ago to dr. Collins and here you
can see
Jim ever wine catherine de Loch Francis
Collins John Mansell Geoff Khan and
these were the committee chairs for a
scientific report and also in
neuroethics report so there's two
reports that have recently been
published available on the web to guide
the second half of the brain initiative
and the second half we intend to stay on
the productive path that was already
launched supporting technology
development and the targeted study of
circuit components in addition there
will be an emphasis on identifying not
only the neural activity but in precise
characterization of the behaviors and
qualitative analysis of behaviors
structures and models particularly in
model organisms we will balance
individual investigator research which
generates the really groundbreaking
ideas with team science that allows you
to get to knowledge that requires large
scale activities such as understanding
all the cells in the mouse brain for
instance as a team project that can only
be done as part of a team and we are
currently thinking about what would be
the most impactful large-scale
transformative projects the mouse brain
cell census project certainly would be a
transformative project what other type
of projects will be the legacy for the
brain initiative in the second half and
and there are a number of which were
suggested in the brain
2.0 for it to dr. Collins Fatali and
we're very excited to have John nigh to
come in to direct the brain initiative
through its second phase it's important
to state that the brain initiative is
not simply an NIH effort there are
multiple federal agencies involved such
as the FDA darpur
I offer the National Science Foundation
for sure has been a tremendous partner
in the brain initiative they're also
nonprofit partners I Triple E the Simons
Foundation the CAV lien and these have
all come together to form the brain
initiative Alliance which is a platform
for funding opportunities and to
promulgate the news and opportunities
and achievements of the brain initiative
to the public the brain initiative is
also a global effort so there are very
related brain initiative research
programs going on in many countries and
they are coordinated that they meet
together at the international brain
initiative to compare notes and to work
particularly in the north ethics space
in a coordinated fashion so there are
brain initiative programs going on in
Canada China the European Union launched
the human brain project just before we
launched at NIH there's an Australian
brain alliance Korean brain initiative
and and the brain minds in Japan with or
with their relevant partner
organizations so just to close I hope
that I was able to convey the importance
of filling in this gap in our knowledge
about how the brain works the excitement
that comes when tools become available
that allow people to answer questions
that they thought never would be
possible to answer during their lifetime
and that's not an understatement because
some of these tools have really been
earth shattering in their impact on
understanding and seeing brain activity
in action in modulating brain activity
and indeed the ability to start to think
creatively about how we can help people
who have circuit disorders that cause
them disability whether it's chronic
pain opioid addiction schizophrenia
depression
and Parkinson's disease in epilepsy well
all the symptoms that a patient will
realize or due to the disordered
circuits that the pathology is causing
but it's really the circuit dysfunction
that leads to the disability so if we
have through the knowledge of the brain
initiative the opportunity to modulate
those circuits for health I think that
the impact will be really everlasting so
stay tuned you're going to hear from a
tremendous cadre of investigators in the
area brain circuits and brain initiative
and enjoy and and try and get hooked on
trying to understand how the brain works
thanks very much thank you dr. Koh no
shots without standing presentation for
additional informative presentations via
our agenda and our events taped and as a
final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you submitted by
email thank you again for your
participation